ja klar eine sexuelle Belästigung
schädigter
vort es ist erst spät am Nachmittag auf
dem kanstadterwasen als Alexei Kalinski
und seine Kollegen zu diesem Einsatz
gerufen werden her kam angerannt hat sie
einfach Vollgas umarmt dekol bekrapscht
am Ohr
gezogen ohne
ank gekommen ist ich war bisschen
handychäftigt auf einm hat mehr als 4
Millionen Besucher sie wollen feiern was
erleben zur Schattenseite gehören Drogen
Schlägereien sexuelle Übergriffe im
vergangenen Jahr nahm die Polizei mehr
als 500 Ordnungswidrigkeiten und
Anzeigen auf es war das erste Jahr nach
Corona die Beamten gehen davon aus dass
es dieses Jahr mehr sein werden vor
allem Frauen fühlen sich unsicher ich
habe sich schon mitbekommen von
Freundinnen
dass teilweise in Schwierigkeiten waren
und dann einfach nicht gewusst hab na
Hause kommen sollen ich habe darauf eher
weniger Lust so irgendwie dumm angemacht
zu werden irgendwie von irgendwelchen
Leuten also betrunkene Leute Männer halt
auch oder dass sie dann ein irgendwie
unsittlich bisschen anfassen ist dir das
schon mal passiert ja muss nicht noch
mal sein also ist kein schönes Gefühl
die Stadt Stuttgart
reagiert kennt ihr schon die vasenbo ne
wir sind ein safepace für Mädchen und
Frauen wir sind dieses Mal das erste Mal
auf dem Volksfest also falls ihr einfach
mal euer Akku laden wollt oder irgendwie
einfach nur ein Schluck trinken wollt
oder falls irwas passieren sollte könnt
ihr uns
zommen viel Spaß
euch ich fin es cool dass ihr das macht
gerade weil was sie gesagt hat dass ein
Handyakku leer geht das passiert
unfassbar schnell dass man jemanden
anrufen kann oder einfach irgendwo
hingehen kann wenn man sich gerade
irgendwie verfolgt fühlt oder unsicher
fühlt fin ich richtig gut manchmal fühlt
man sich als Mädchen schon gerade wenn
halt so viele betruckten hier rumlaufen
hat man bisschen wenn alleine nach Hause
läuft oder so bisschen Schiss aber
deswegen ich glaub das ist schon guter
Anlaufpunkt nadja ist Sozialarbeiterin
Sonja Studentin weil sie wissen dass
hier später am Abend viele betrunken
sein werden verteilen sie Flyer
informieren die Mitarbeiter und
Besucherinnen möglichst viele sollen von
ihrem Angebot wissen manche aber
kritisieren
sie da ist gerade Mitarbeiter auf mich
zugekommen der war ein bisschen
angetrunken und hat so gemeint von wegen
dass er das diskriminierend finde nur
für Mädchen und Frauen ist dieser space
und ja da habe ich mir auch weil er sich
ja vielleicht auch wie eine Frau fühlt
und hab dann einfach erklärt dass wenn
er sich wirklich nicht gut fühlt dann
werden wir ih nicht stehen lassen
sondern werden ihn irgendwo weiter
vermitteln andere haben
Verständnis also ich find's gut dass es
sowas gibt speziell für Frauen weil die
bräuchten halt auch ein Rückzugsort von
der sag ich mal männlichen Welt wenn die
halt jetzt zu bisher belächtigen und so
also wenn her Frau läuft entweder
Telefongespräch faken oder die
Straßenseite wechseln einfach das
angenehmer wird dass man nicht als der
creep abgestempelt wird zurück zur
wasasenstreife der Mann der sich auf
zwei junge Frauen gestürzt haben soll
wird festgenommen ma dann so dass du mit
dem beschuldig und wir laufen
Geschä der mutmaßliche Täter hat keinen
Personalausweis dabei muss mit auf die
vasenwache ihm drohen wegen sexueller
Belästigung eine Geldstrafe oder eine
Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu Z Jahren die
beiden Frauen stehen unter Schock also
wir saßen halt dort auf den Treppen und
dann kam halt dieser Mann aus dem Nichts
mit geöffneten Arm und hat sie dann
richtig eng in die Arme genommen
umarmt hier so bin ich halt auch direkt
aufgestanden ich habe den Mann auch so
auf Rücken geschlagen auf Kopf
geschlagen so einfach aus Reflex ich hab
angefangen dann zu schrei ich auch die
ganze Zeit gezittert und wir haben gar
nicht damit gerechnet dass SAS passiert
man hört es zwar schon so von außen rum
so ja hier das passiert dort aber so
persönlich bin ich noch nie damit in
Kontakt gekommen auf der Wache werden
die Beamten ihre Aussagen dokumentieren
für Kalinski Routine es ist nicht schön
selbstverständlich aber im Endeffekt ist
unser Job wir müssen professionell
bleiben es ist ein Fall von vielen an
diesem Tag die Polizei wird Jugendliche
kontrollieren die trinken und rauchen
exasy beschlagnahmen und bei
Schlägereien
Eingreifen an der wasasenburje hat das
Team rund um Nadja eine junge Frau
aufgenommen
die Polizei hat sie gebracht weil die H
sie neben Zelt V Zelt die war sehr
unglücklich und hat geweint oder so
bisschen verzweifelt und die haben sie
einfach also gefunden aber die also sie
haben ser angesprochen und genau dann
hat sie kurz geschildert und dann haben
die gesagt das wäre vielleicht hier der
richtige Ort sie ist jetzt alleine sie
will jetzt biss sich sie legt sich
gerade hin und RT sich ein bisschen aus
und
überlegt meine Angebote vielleicht mit
Taxi fahren kann genau die junge Frau
ist sehr betrunken damit sie nicht
alleine fahren muss versuchen Nadja und
Sonja ihre Freundinnen zu finden Lisa
bist du schon aus dem Zelt
draußen okay alles klar wir laufen auch
gerade rüber tschüss die Zelte schließen
bald die ersten sind auf dem Heimweg es
ist voll und
unübersichtlich wie willst du sie jetzt
erkennen also also wir haben tatsächlich
gleich zu ihr gesagt dass wir halt
dieses Logo haben dass wir von der en wo
sind und ich hoffe dass sie uns halt
erkennt mitten im Getümmel treffen sie
die Gruppe die Frauen dachten ihre
Freundin sei schon zu Hause wussten
nicht wie schlecht es ihr geht zusammen
warten Sie jetzt auf das
Taxi mehr als H Mal wird das
wasasenburenam bis Ende des diesjährigen
Volksfests geholfen haben vor allem
alkoholisierten und desorientierten
Mädchen und Frauen um sich sicherer zu
fühlen bereiten sich manche
BesucherInnen extra vor eigentlich immer
eine kurze Hose drunterziehen habe ich
gerade auch an sehr viele Freundinnen
von mir die haben meinen Standort wir
haben uns alle auf feindm von Apple aber
sonst also ich rufemer jemanden an dann
telefonier ich mit dem während ich heim
laufe ich würde mich sicherer fühlen
wenn ich Pfefferspray dabei hätte oder
mit jemanden unterwegs bin wie z.B mit
meinem Bruder oder mein Vater oder sowas
das Taxi ist da als die Buden schon zu
sind diese drei Frauen werden sicher
nach Hause kommen
also
hab das schon echter wit